and for more on the story we're joined
now in the studio by say Ron Artest she
founded a liberal mosque in Berlin where
men and women pray together and women
can also lead prayers as an imam she
also initiated the idea of the so-called
mosque tax thank you for being with us
this morning
miss Aisha why do you think the funding
model model in Germany for mosques
should be changed it should be changed
because we have a huge influence from
outside from foreign countries
what kind of Islam is educated in
Germany this influence has to be cut the
influence is controlling all the
education is controlling the mosques is
controlling the way how we teach Islam
here now we have this is bad because we
have this influence made that Muslims a
lot of Muslims are not able to integrate
themselves or their families here in
Germany or Europe we have all these
problems all over Europe it's not only a
German problem we have a big influence
here in Germany especially from Turkey
or from the Muslim Brotherhood so we
have to cut this influence to give the
Muslims a chance to have or to call
Germany as their home country and to
think about new ways of education this
is the motivation behind the idea of the
text the motivation is to cut the
influence from outside when it comes to
the Imams education and to teach them or
when it comes to the prayers in the
mosque okay so looking at Germany's
Muslim community as a whole
it's sizable is there a lot of support
for reforming the way mosques are funded
within that community as a whole I think
a lot of Muslims are not happy in the
situation what we have when we talk
about Islam so we talked mostly about
violence or terrorists so there is a
need that we have to change those
pictures that's the reason why in my
opinion people starts
about new models we have to start to
think about the integration of Islam in
Germany in another way than the
association's did in the past we say to
change to change the way Muslims are
perceived in Germany is that what you're
referring to those things on one side we
have to change the way how people look
to Islam and how the Muslims themselves
have the influence here they have to
stand up themselves they have to take
care about their own religion here in
Germany so Muslims in Germany should do
something for Islam in Germany so do you
see a consensus building long term for
for your position on this how do you go
about convincing Germany's more
conservative Muslim community to support
your idea the first step should be to
cut the financial influence and the next
step should be to bring together the
pure ality of Islam on one table and
discuss about something like a text we
cannot take the idea of the church text
what we have in German law and put it on
Islam this is not possible so we should
take think about new models and my
opinion would be or my offer would be to
think about a kind you know we have the
five pillars of Islam and one of the
pillar is the social text so we should
name it different maybe then the public
can understand it better okay siren
artists
thank you so much for talking with us
today session